now these days batteries are one of the
sexiest things when it comes to business
everyone wants to have gigafactories
making loads of batteries for electric
cars it's a big new thing
but here's a couple of interesting
perhaps unexpected little nuggets back
in the day the first country where
Lithium-ion batteries were actually
invented was actually the UK they
invented it in Oxford the chemistry the
main bit of the chemistry for the
cathodes was invented in Oxford back in
the 80s and second facts a lot of people
assumed that we didn't we never really
made batteries in this country that the
mostly they were made off in in Asia
actually
they were and this place is part of the
answer there we are in the northernmost
town in Mainland uh Britain Thursday
just near John o'groats and we're in a
factory uh that is these days part of a
company called empty it used to be
called AGM and this Machinery has been
making uh batteries Lithium-ion
batteries for decades this whole place
goes back kind of 30 years or more and
it was making them not for camcorders
but for military applications radios
things like that and you can see the
Machinery here it's a fascinating
process
um this is where you're basically baking
uh the materials that important
chemicals onto thin uh bits of sheets of
foil basically kind of aluminum foil and
copper foil and that gets kind of baked
onto them and you end up with either a
cathode or a nano they're kind of a long
stream of metal coats coated with
chemicals and then it goes through here
this kind of bit bit like ovens where
it's coating them and baking them it
goes all the way along here along in
these rolls and what you get the end is
a kind of a roll of this stuff it's foil
but it's got the chemicals on the
outside okay so that looks like that's a
cathode there because it's got aluminum
foil but come over here and we'll show
you what happens to that next so it
starts it starts off over there and then
it goes here and it gets kind of this is
a kind of called a calendaring machine
and this is where it gets compressed so
it goes through all of these different
roles making it getting it down to kind
of Micron thickness it goes and once it
ends up after that machine
um you've got a whole other set of
processes which you know too many for us
to show you just uh in one go but also
you're slicing the the different kind of
anodes and cathos uh into the right kind
of shape there what you end up with are
a number of different types of cells
and what's interesting about this place
okay
is that they have exciting new plans for
the future to make cells that go into
kind of high performance cars cells that
you can put in under the bottom of the
ground and not need to replace that
lasts for six years cells that are for
energy storage so sodium ion batteries
so not quite lithium ion but sodium ion
batteries these kinds of things you can
put them away for storage and that's
going to last for a long time it says
Ultra safe that's because sodium it's
sodium ion it's basically cut through
that it's not going to explode like a
Lithium-Ion battery but what's
interesting about this kind of situation
and where we are right now at the moment
is the US is pouring hundreds of
billions of dollars into batteries into
renewable energy Europe is doing
something similar as well the UK is not
and that's raising questions about
whether a business like this quite an
important business with a big history
behind it really wants to invest in the
UK or whether they're looking at what's
happening in the US and saying oh maybe
that's a better deal over there so big
questions for the UK government about
what whether they're going to support
the energy transition